the next question is regarding
injections is it permitted during the
fast as far injections are concern there
are different types of injections it can
be intravenous injection it can be
intramuscular injection it can be subut
injection but the injections can broadly
be classified in two types one type of
injection which gives a person a
nourishment which is equivalent to
giving
food for example if you take an
intravenous glucose
the people who have excessive
dehydration Etc and cannot take food by
the mouth so normally the medical
treatment is giving intravenous glucose
this is sort of nourishment it is
equivalent to giving food this will
break the fast but if it's not a
nourishment if it's only a medical
treatment like insulin it can be
subcutaneously or it is penicilin all
these Medical Treatments which are not
nourishment to the body are not somewhat
like food these can be given during the
daytime and the fast will not break
though there are some Scholars who say
that it's m or discouraged it's
preferable if it taken after the sunset
but the right ruling is that it does not
break the fast because it's not any sort
of food